ça y est les premiers joueurs de
l'équipe de France sont arrivés en fin
de matinée dans les Yvelines à
Clairefontaine pour le stage de
préparation à la Coupe du monde de
football vous entendrez dans quelques
instants les premières réactions de
Didier Deschamps en conférence de presse
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 7 8
sport c'est parti pour 26 nouvelles
minutes de direct et on passe tout de
suite évidemment au titre en images de
cette édition le vélodrome de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines accueillait ce
jeudi la Coupe de France de la course à
l'américaine l'occasion de découvrir
cette épreuve sur piste par équipe et
très stratégique depuis quelques années
les sportifs de haut niveau utilisent de
nombreuses méthodes innovantes pour
récupérer entre les compétitions comme
la cryothérapie nous avons suivi une
séance cette semaine avec l'équipe de
France de BMX évidemment comme
d'habitude en fin d'émission tous les
résultats du week-end mais je vous le
disais c'était la première image de
cette émission les premiers joueurs de
l'équipe de France sont arrivés
aujourd'hui en fin de matinée à
Clairefontaine ils sont 8 et joue tous
dans le championnat anglais la première
ligue parmi eux le gardien évidemment
Hugo Lloris ou encore le défenseur
Mamadou Sakho les autres joueurs
arriveront à partir de mercredi et ce
jusqu'à ce week-end et un début de stage
qui va qui a vu le forfait de dernière
minute de Steve Mandanda le gardien de
l'Olympique de Marseille ne participera
pas à cette coupe du monde au Brésil la
réaction de du sélectionneur Didier
Deschamps au micro de Patrick Jacques
denixmude
je suis triste pour lui ses camarades
aussi
c'est des choses qui peuvent arriver
malheureusement et là aujourd'hui voilà
c'est c'est un jouable pour lui de
pouvoir espérer être disponible par
rapport à ce qui nous attend donc allez
on passe tout de suite à notre page
sport universitaire
ce samedi 24 mai l'université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin va participer
pour la première fois au challenge du
monde des grandes écoles et université
une compétition un petit peu à part
entière dans le paysage sportif on n'a
pas l'habitude d'en voir de telles
sortent et les hommes à la base de cette
candidature sur Versailles Saint-Quentin
sans présence le président et le
vice-président de l'association VSQ
sport and work pour ne pas faire de
fautes Geoffrey Delmotte le président
bonsoir à vous et vous êtes accompagné
de Julien denervo votre vice-président
merci d'être là tous les deux on parlera
tout à l'heure évidemment à côté d'où il
y a Annick bouquet mère adjointe de la
ville de Versailles à la petite enfance
pour parler de cette cinquième édition
des Olympiades du livre ensemble alors
on revient à ce sport universitaire vous
allez donc participer à ce challenge
expliquez-nous un peu le concept
Geoffrey alors le challenge du monde des
grandes écoles et des universités a lieu
cette année dans sa sixième édition
aura lieu au stade Charléty à Paris dans
le 13e arrondissement et ça reg groupe
80 équipes d'universités de grandes
écoles françaises et européennes qui se
rencontrent dans un meeting d'athlétisme
dans un tournoi de football avec un fort
métier original dans une ambiance
conviviale et décontractée il y a
évidemment cet enjeu sportif j'imagine
que c'est ce qui vous a suivi séduit un
petit peu à la base de ce projet Julien
oui bah totalement en plus en plus de ce
côté sportif le côté humain qu'il y a
derrière pour comment dire souder les
étudiants de l'université de
Saint-Quentin pouvoir revendiquer que
nous sommes fiers de l'USQ et alors
comment s'est passé votre préparation
sur ces quelques mois je sais que le
projet a vraiment été lancé depuis le
mois de janvier concrètement comment ça
s'est passé au niveau tantôt au niveau
physique que organisationnel logistique
Geoffrey au niveau organisation nous
avons assisté à la conférence de
lancement du cdmj qui a eu lieu le 16
janvier à la mairie de Paris et c'est à
partir de cette dette là que on a mis
qu'on a tout mis en route on a créé
l'association puisqu'on est plus jeune
on a été créé au mois de janvier et
ensuite on allait voir l'administration
de l'Université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin pour faire part du projet
on est allé voir la ville de Guyancourt
pour avoir une infrastructure sportive
qui est le gymnase des droits de l'homme
sur Guyancourt et on nous avons aussi
des marchés à la communauté
d'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines
pour qu'on puisse avoir une aide dans le
cadre de ce projet alors du coup après
il y a évidemment la préparation
physique puisque ça reste une épreuve et
une compétition ce challenge commence à
s’est passé derrière Julien vous vous
êtes encadré de coach sur chaque
activité je pense à l'athlétisme au
football oui bah justement donc des
étudiants qui étaient volontaires pour
participer au projet avec nous donc
plutôt axé sur le sport justement
puisque nous on s'occupait plus de côté
logistique organisation donc a permis
d'avoir comment dire un entraînement
assez carré des des sessions
hebdomadaires j'imagine assez rigoureuse
pour pas partir un petit peu dans tous
les sens peut-être oui voilà c'est ça
donc c'est notamment le le rôle de
d'Iris et d'Adrien qui sont chargés de
l'athlétisme et du football et alors du
coup par exemple pour vous deux vous
étiez footballeur athlète auparavant ou
c'est vous vous êtes lancé dans ces
disciplines pour le challenge alors pour
ma part je faisais pas de sport en club
mais je cours beaucoup donc du coup je
participe au 10 km le 24 mai et pour toi
Julien bah écoutez non moi je ne fais
pas sport je fais beaucoup de sport
plusieurs notamment du handball mais qui
n'était pas proposé là très bien alors
du coup il va y avoir à peu près 7000
participants il y a des des facultés des
grandes écoles d'un peu partout en
France mais aussi en Europe et du coup
ça va ça va être une belle fête du sport
mais aussi de la convivialité c'est ça
on peut rencontrer en fait des étudiants
qui viennent de différents horizons et
j'en profite aussi que depuis le début
j'étais en relation très régulièrement
avec Amir qui est à l'université
d'Aix-Marseille et qui m'a donné
quelques petits tuyaux parce que ça
faisait la quatrième fois lui qui
participer avec sa fac donc voilà si
nous regarde je fais un petit coucou
alors du coup par rapport à cette
compétition j'imagine qu'il va y avoir
des objectifs sportifs envie de gagner
un trophée parce qu'il y a des trophées
un petit peu originaux le trophée des
meilleurs supporters la meilleure
mascotte il y a pas mal de petites
choses qui tournent autour de la
compétition à promo à proprement parler
c'est quoi votre objectif prioritaire
sur ce challenge
côté on va dire côté supporters
l'objectif c'est d'être le d'être les
meilleurs supporters vous allez évoluer
presque à la maison en plus vous êtes
pas très loin du stade Charléty
exactement et donc un petit objectif on
va dire personnel c'est donc de battre
Amir et ses équipes d'Aix-Marseille à la
rivalité on va dire parisienne Marseille
est encore présente sur le challenge des
universités exactement tout à fait du
coup par rapport à cette organisation et
à ce tournoi j'imagine que il y avait
aussi toute cette sensation de se dire
on est fier d'appartenir à notre faculté
c'est ce que vous disiez un que tout à
l'heure c'est quelque chose qui est pas
très présent à l'université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin disons que de
manière générale quand on regarde les
grandes écoles françaises il y a un
sentiment d'appartenance qui est très
fort alors que dans les universités
françaises et ça c'est peut-être dû
aussi parce que
c'est une offre une structure qui est
beaucoup plus grande parce qu'il y a
plusieurs sites comme on voit là sur
l'université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
qui est sur plusieurs villes nous on
avait aussi envie de donner cette envie
de d'appartenir à l'université et d'être
fier de la représenter dans un événement
sportif qui est aussi fait pour ça oui
en plus essayez peut-être de
contrecarrer les les widires sur la
faculté les problèmes financiers qu'il y
a en ce moment ça permet peut-être de
passer à autre chose c'est ça de passer
outre et de montrer que malgré les
problèmes dont on parle beaucoup en ce
moment et bien il y a des étudiants qui
sont là qui sont fiers de représenter
leur université et et vous serez presque
enfin plus d'une quarantaine en tout cas
à représenter l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin ce weekend au stade charlé
oui ça après c'est d'un point de vue
athlète footballeur et staff staff du
CDG u VSQ voilà après donc les
supporters on espère bien approcher plus
de la centaine de personnes très bien
donc du coup on se donne rendez-vous ce
samedi 24 mai si vous voulez aller les
supporter nos étudiants de la
l'université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
partir de 7h30 il faudra se lever tôt au
stade Charles ETI merci beaucoup à tous
les deux d'être passé sur le site du
sport on suivra ça évidemment de près ce
weekend le vélodrome de 50 ans en
Yvelines j'en parlais dans les titres
accueillaient ce jeudi la Coupe de
France de la course à l'américaine
l'occasion de découvrir cette épreuve
sur piste par équipe et très stratégique
images de Jonathan Wilm
au sein de ce peloton d'une quarantaine
d'unités Thomas boudaib Bryan Coquard
sont évidemment les grands favoris de
cette Coupe de France de l'américaine
avec au programme 160 tours de pistes et
des efforts intenses que le vie champion
olympique 2012 n'a plus ressenti depuis
les championnats d'Europe espoir l'été
dernier on tape jamais autant autant de
dents que sur un vélo drone et sur une
Américaine principalement c'est c'est
des efforts violents difficiles et je
pense qu'il y a rien de mieux pour
progresser et vraiment ça fait vraiment
beaucoup beaucoup de bien la course à
l'américaine est une épreuve au point
mais aussi de distance le but est de
prendre des tours à l'adversaire les
vainqueurs sont également partagés par
les points à qui lors des sprints
intermédiaires le champion du monde de
l'omium 2014 sort d'un stage avec
l'équipe de France sur piste et connaît
la recette pour décrocher un nouveau
titre c'est encore plus stratégique
parce que ça se fait vraiment à rien
parce qu'on est souvent plein d'équipes
au même niveau
et ça se joue à une attaque à un demi
tour près si on la place bien comme il
faut Thomas bouda et Bryan Coquard vont
rapidement placer une attaque décisive
après 30 passages l'équipe des Pays de
la Loire reprend un tour au peloton et
s'assure la victoire à plus de 50 km/h
de moyenne les deux prodiges s'imposent
finalement avec trois tours d'avance de
quoi faire respectivement le plein de
confiance avant les Championnats
d'Europe sur piste et le Tour de France
allez on passe au rugby féminin et ce
mercredi le Rugby Club de Versailles
organisé un tournoi de rugby à 7 la
l'initiative à l'objectif très claire
démocratisé la discipline chez les deux
moiselles au bord du terrain pour tvfils
Olivier Maniscalco et Jérémy et brasse
Noura à 15 ans grâce à l'Association
Sportive de son collège elle pratique le
rugby depuis deux ans et elle compte
bien continuer le problème c'est que je
passe au lycée donc après il y aura plus
de rugby mais j'aimerais bien faire un
plat ouais ça serait cool
problème pour Nora trouver un club sera
difficile à partir de 15 ans les jeunes
filles ne sont plus incorporés aux
équipes de garçons et trouver une équipe
féminine et compliquée à la fin de la
saison 2013 la Fédération française de
rugby ne comptait 11500 licences loin
des 266 licences masculines organisée
par le Rugby Club de Versailles ce
tournoi opposé des jeunes Yvelines
toutes pratiques le rugby grâce à leurs
collèges elles sont donc encore en train
de découvrir et d'apprendre ce sport
l'enjeu de la compétition et même
ailleurs que dans la victoire le
principe en fait est de développer le
rugby féminin donc au travers des
catégories qui sont actuellement au
collège donc les moins de 13 ans des
moins de 15 ans donc de 11 à 15 ans et
de permettre aux associations sportives
au collège de se rencontrer au sein du
département de faire des compétitions le
rugby est souvent présenté comme un
sport d'homme un cliché qu'il faut
battre en brèche selon Nicolas loubard
les filles prennent du plaisir à jouer à
ce jeu qui a un jeu d'affrontement des
vêtements et qui aussi intellectuel dans
la réflexion du jeu donc en fait ouais
il y a un réel plaisir et en août
prochain le rugby féminin va bénéficier
d'une formidable publicité puisque la
France va accueillir la Coupe du monde
après la victoire des Bleus dans le
tournoi des 6 nations c'est une occasion
en or pour poursuivre le développement
de la discipline car ces jeunes filles
ne rêvent que d'une chose continuèrent à
marquer des essais
allez on passe à la cinquième édition
des Olympiades de Versailles
cet événement est décidément maintenant
vraiment admis et complètement incorporé
dans l'agenda sportif de l'année c'est
évidemment les Olympiades de Versailles
cette cinquième édition qui est
organisée notamment par Annick bouquet
la nouvelle mère adjointe à la petite
enfance de Versailles bonsoir à vous
merci d'être là tout d'abord pour
rappeler un petit peu le concept des
Olympiades pour les téléspectateurs
expliquer nous un peu comment ça va se
dérouler ce week-end ce samedi alors ça
se passe sur toute la journée donc on
accueille les toutes les personnes quel
qu'il soit de tout âge de toutes les
formes non valides ou valides et ils ont
le choix de participer à différents
ateliers très divers alors le matin il y
a la piscine et l'équitation je le
spécifie parce que ça a lieu que le
matin mais il y a l'escalade il y a de
la Ligue du judo il y a il va avoir
aussi un parcours en ville enfin il y a
du terralar il y a de la pétanque il y a
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup d'ateliers
l'objectif de ces olympiades il faut le
rappeler c'est évidemment de de mixer un
petit peu mélanger les sportifs valides
et les sport non valide qu'on puisse
pratiquer un sport tous ensemble c'est
surtout surtout j'ai envie de dire
justement c'est le nom de l'association
c'est le vivre ensemble parce que je
suis convaincue que à travers cette
différence et bien on va apprendre à
vivre ensemble parce que vivre ensemble
c'est justement le respect de la
différence et la bienveillance et
s'adapter à l'autre et donc cette
journée est importante et il y a quelque
chose d'assez curieux dans l'histoire de
ces olympiades c'est qu'en fin de compte
elles ont pris un peu naissance il y a
fort longtemps puisque ça a été d'abord
une première idée sur la ville de
Versailles dans les années 70 d'un
ancien ma mère adjoint je crois c'est ça
avec le professeur le jeune qui avait
fait des ateliers un peu sportifs pour
les gens enfin pour les personnes sous
forme d'handicap plus particulièrement
la trisomie voilà et donc on a repris
l'idée il y a 5 ans et on a décidé
justement de parce que moi je suis
partie d'une association qui s'appelle
d'une d'espoir et je me suis rendue
compte que j'avais l'impression de
partir pour faire une BA et en fait en
fait non je recevais beaucoup plus grâce
à ces personnes et du coup en 2014
l'objectif de cette Olympiades c'est
aussi peut-être de favoriser l'insertion
des personnes handicapées et notamment
dans le sport avec tous ces ateliers
exactement de ce que les associations
sportives valident se rendent compte
qu'elles peuvent intégrer des personnes
handicapées au sein de leur de leur
sport vous trouvez vous estimez qu'il y
a encore un peu trop d'exclusion de ces
sportifs non valide par rapport à des
clubs qui sont pas encore équipés ou qui
n'ont pas encore l'expérience de ce
genre de situation l'exclusion je
pourrais dire qu'elle est dans les deux
sens c'est pas seulement les
associations sportives valides mais
c'est aussi les non-valides qui pensent
que ce tel et tel sport n'est pas fait
pour eux et cette journée va leur
montrer que c'est tout à fait possible
alors depuis cinq ans ça a dû faire un
peu changer les mentalités parce qu'on
sait qu'il y a de plus en plus de succès
auprès de ces olympiades vous attendez
près de 1000 participants cette année du
coup est-ce que vous voyez justement les
changements peut-être des partenariats
se tisser entre des clubs et puis
d'autres associations oui il y a des
associations qui sont plus ou plus
ouvertes intégrer justement le handicap
ça c'est dans la ville de Versailles je
fais le je peux le souligner oui et par
rapport à d'autres partenariats que vous
êtes en train de signer je crois il y a
des choses qui commencent à évoluer
aussi mais je pense aussi que dans le
handicap on se rend compte que le sport
est très important et de plus en plus
important donc c'est vrai que c'est une
idée conventions avec l'hôpital Bullion
avec plaisir avec Richebourg mais dans
ou même de handicap mental tout le monde
s'est rendu compte de l'importance du
sport et grâce à cette journée est-ce
que justement il y a des personnes
handicapées qui viennent qui découvrent
un sport et puis qui s'inscrivent ils se
disent en fin de compte je peux aussi
faire du football parce qu'on appelle le
Cécifoot par exemple pour les personnes
non-voyantes ou du hands fauteuil ou
autre chose de l'escalade c'est tout est
jouable tout est jouable exactement
alors je ne suis pas chaque chaque
personne mais c'est vraiment pour
sensibiliser dans tous les sens mais
aussi sensibiliser les valides de se
dire que ben c'est justement l'aventure
humaine c'est dans la différence qu'elle
se trouve alors il va y avoir un un
petit peu particulier cette année que
l'on connaît bien TV fils c'est Yohan
kiou le l'espoir du tennis fauteuil
français qui est qui est rambolique
aussi également et ça c'est un parrain
qui sera là en tout cas présent toute la
journée toute la journée alors on a
vraiment cette chance parce que c'est un
jeune homme formidable qui en fait est
devenu on va dire non valide suite à une
maladie très grave le cancer il a été
donc subi une amputation et il a
découvert le sport tardivement le tennis
et en fait il fait de la compétition en
fauteuil depuis 2008 et comme il dit je
pense que le sport lui a appris à se
dépasser et le but à l'heure actuelle
c'est d'aller au sport handisport au
sport olympique
et je pense qu'il atteindra et pour lui
c'est important l'entraide le respect de
la différence et de dire à tout le monde
voyez j'ai eu un handicap mais ça
m'empêche pas d'aller là où je veux très
bien donc on se donne rendez-vous au
stade Montbauron on comme d'habitude et
puis un petit peu partout dans la ville
pour les différentes animations à partir
de 9 heures
merci beaucoup d'être passé sur le
plateau du 7 8 sport depuis quelques
années les sportifs de haut niveau
utilisent de nombreuses méthodes
innovantes pour récupérer entre les
compétitions comme la cryothérapie un
entrepreneur et mimontin a lancé une
unité mobile nous avons suivi une séance
avec Elodie moine
c'est une grande première pour Quentin
qu'elle est ronde pour effacer quelques
douleurs musculaires avant une étape de
coupe du monde le leader de la Coupe de
France de BMX entre dans cette cabine
remplie d'azote dont le thermomètre
avoisine les moins 140 degrés en
l'espace de 3 minutes le corps humain
subite une telle chute de température
cutanée qu'elle permet de régénérer les
cellules de l'organisme on sent assez
bien tout de suite après c'est vrai que
à l'intérieur bon ben il fait vraiment
froid donc c'est un peu bizarre c'est la
première fois que je le fais
bon après je j'ai une coupe du monde ce
week-end donc bon on va voir ce que ça
donne déjà cet après-midi pour un petit
peu les effets avec l'enchaînement des
matchs et des compétitions l'aspect
récupération occupe désormais une place
de choix dans le planning des sportifs
de haut niveau si les sports les plus
populaires sont désormais habitués à la
cryothérapie d'autres disciplines comme
le triathlon ou le BMX commence tout
juste à s'y intéresser
on supporte beaucoup mieux les impacts
et après un match comme ils ont des
Bleus énormément de bleu en
traumatologie en entier de matos c'est
vraiment très très bien ils dorment
beaucoup mieux après depuis 2011 ce
camion permet à cette entrepreneur
inhi-montain de suivre des équipes
professionnelles sur le Tour de France
ou encore le Rugby Club Toulonnais une
unité mobile dont le budget s'élève à
130 000 euros
en rugby plaisir à un pied en 8e de
finale ce dimanche les plaisirs rois se
déplaçaient sur la pelouse de Chartres
et pour le match aller des 16e de finale
de Fédérale 3 les joueurs de Philibert
se sont imposés 10 à 3 de quoi préparer
sereinement le match retour ce dimanche
à plaisir pour rappel en cas de
qualification pour les huitièmes et bien
le PRC validerait son billet pour la
montée en Fédérale 2 en foutue S et de
deux pour les Templiers pour la deuxième
journée de poules de Ligue des Champions
et l'encours s'est imposé face au
pioneerz de Barcelone 34 à 16 un succès
qui permet au templier de se qualifier
pour les phases finales les 11 12 et 13
juillet prochain en football fortune
opposé pour trap aiguille en course il
trap a été étriers 5 buts à 1 à
Saint-Ouen-l'Aumône le SG recevait ce
dimanche le 9e Saint-Maur concurrent
direct pour le maintien et vous le voyez
Guyancourt c'est incliné 2 à 1 et 7
11ème défaite de la saison complique
sérieusement les affaires de l'ESG le
club est à nouveau relégable à la 11e
place avec 39 points à deux longueurs du
PEC et à 3 de Saint-Maur et cela avant
un déplacement qui ce qui sent le soufre
ce week-end sur la pelouse du 8e Lugia
machiabi Paris ce dimanche toujours en
football Division d'Honneur deuxième
défaite consécutive pour Versailles qui
s'éteintée ce dimanche sur la pelouse
des Lilas Debussy les joueurs de David
Giguet conservent tout de même leurs
quatrième place au classement général
handball après ça 5e place lors de la
seconde phase des championnats des moins
de 18 ans championnats de France plaisir
et été réservé reversé pardon en phase
finale d'excellence et accueillez les 8e
de finale ce week-end opposé à
l'alliance sud Bretagne les plaisirsois
en noir ne partait pas favoris pourtant
à la pose il rentre au vestiaire avec
seulement un but de retard 14 à 15 et
c'est dans les ultimes minute de jeu que
les joueurs d'Alexandre Taillefer
pousser par leur public force la
décision et s'impose finalement d'un
tout petit but 31 à 30
Alex ordinaire nous on a un tout petit
club on évolue en région face à une
entente ambassade Bretagne qui ont on
leur met à l'équipe en les mains déjà
nous on était super heureux de finir
meilleur 5e pour recevoir chez nous vous
avez vu depuis qu'il y a il
extraordinaire et c'est ce qui permet de
me permettre de gagner le match à la fin
d'un but alors qu'on mener d'un but à la
mi-temps et qu'on a été mené quasiment
toute la seconde mi-temps sauf les cinq
dernières en Europe passé devant donc
moi je suis très fermé les joueurs et il
y a eu une allégation incroyable et il
faut croire contre la nuit de samedi à
dimanche et bien les plaisirs ont bien
dormi puisqu'ils se sont à nouveau
imposés en quart de finale face à Cernay
ce dimanche encore par un tout petit but
d'écart 27 à 26 plaisirs affrontera donc
Vénissieux en demi-finale le 31 mai
prochain à Perpignan du handball féminin
en page chez les femmes et pour le
compte de la 22e et dernière journée de
Nationale de Montigny se déplaçait à
Reims mais les immigrantaines n'ont pas
terminé la saison sur une bonne note
elle s'incline 25 à 24 et termine donc
cet exercice 2013 2014 elle a 6e place
vous allez le voir au classement cela
s'affiche voilà les donc sixième au
classement final une dernière info et
encore une belle boisson de médaille
pour Yann dujarrier vous nous l'avions
fait découvrir à l'automne dernier il
continue sa moisson de titres le roller
men après la couronne européenne sur
piste levelyséen qui concourt également
sur les rollers vous le voyez à l'image
et devenu ce weekend champion de France
sur le kilomètre décidément sa
spécialité pour le plaisir Yann dujariet
a récolté l'argent sur le 500 mètres en
baseball cinquième journée de Division 2
Montigny se déplaçait sur le terrain du
Pôle France et chaque équipe a eu son
match ce dimanche d'abord Montigny le
matin qui gagne 8 à 4 puis le pôle 10 à
9 l'après-midi les cougar reste deuxième
de leur poule avec cette victoire en 10
matchs et un grand merci à Charles Ellie
Froidevaux pour ses nouvelles
infographies que vous avez pu découvrir
ce soir on se retrouve évidemment la
semaine prochaine c'est la fin de cette
édition je vous souhaite quant à moi une
excellente soirée sur TV film